you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
yet more records broken as it's revealed
europe experienced its hottest year ever
in 2020
a warning summer holiday trips to
tourist hot spots could be under threat
from climate change
and should beavers be reintroduced to
the wild in england
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show now last year was the
hottest year on record in europe with
the average temperature across the
continent reaching nearly two degrees
more than the long-term average that's
from the latest in an annual series of
global climate reports it shows how
temperatures in europe have been
increasing in recent years reaching a
record level in 2020. now all five of
the warmest years
four annual average temperatures have
occurred since 2014. now when we look at
what that meant for individual countries
many places especially in eastern europe
reported their highest ever yearly
average temperatures in 2020. now russia
was nearly three degrees above the
average from 1981 to 2010 while estonia
finland and ukraine were all above two
degrees warmer
now although parts of western europe
were relatively cooler
countries still recorded temperatures up
to two degrees above the average for the
long-term period and the uk
had its third warmest year since
national records began at an average of
0.8 degrees warmer than normal and the
report also found that globally
atmospheric concentrations of the three
main greenhouse gases carbon dioxide
methane and nitrous oxide reached record
values in 2020 despite lockdowns because
of the covert 19 pandemic
well joining me now is dr robert dunn
senior climate scientist at the met
office who was the lead editor for the
global climate chapter of that report
welcome to you first of all how sure can
we be that human-induced climate change
is responsible for this record average
temperature rise in europe
what we can say is from the recent ipcc
that on a global level
climate ruling climate and extreme um
warmer temperatures
is unequivocally due to human actions
and what we see in europe in 2020 this
1.9 degrees above the baseline average
is part of that picture but it's not the
only thing that's going on
and what are the effects of the
increasing temperatures around the world
what impact do they have
so during 2020 we saw the warmest
temperature recorded since 1931 anywhere
in the globe at 54.4 degrees in death
valley um that was actually then equaled
again likely this year
um globally we see that 2020 was one of
the top three warmest years on record
that's the same as for the uk as you
just said but we see increased
temperatures elsewhere as well so we had
a record temperature of 18.3 degrees on
the continent of antarctica
and actually in the arctic circle we saw
a record temperature of 38 degrees so
we're seeing high temperatures across
the world but we're also seeing the
response of the climate to that so
mountain glaciers are still losing mass
and their ice is melting we're seeing
permafrost temperatures reaching record
values
um
northern hemisphere lakes are covered
with ice for less time 8.5 days fewer
last year but also our biosphere is
responding so colleagues here at the uk
met office studying how oak trees are
responding to the warming temperatures
and their leaves are coming out earlier
and they came into earth earlier
earliest in any time the last 20 years
in 2020
and what about concentrations of
greenhouse gases were you surprised for
example they didn't drop during the
lockdown months
given the kobe pandemic
in the state of the climate report we
see that the
emissions of greenhouse gases in 2020
were a bit lower than what we'd expected
by about six to seven percent
that's a small change but it does show
that
some of the effects of the kobe 19
epidemic and the lockdowns means that
if we act as a global society we can
change how much we emit but by just
reducing the emissions we're still
putting more stuff into the atmosphere
and therefore the um the concentrations
we see are still rising
dr robert dunn thanks very much indeed
thank you let's take a look now at some
of the day's other climate news and
authorities in tennessee say they've
accounted for dozens of people who were
previously listed as missing after
flooding killed at least 21 people in
the u.s state over the weekend
scientists say that climate change will
make extreme weather events like
flooding and wildfires more likely
people won't be able to reduce the
amount of greenhouse gases emitted from
their homes unless the government does
more to help according to consumer
groups they've written to the prime
minister saying it's too expensive
complicated and risky for people to
decarbonize their houses
england's homes produce more carbon
emissions every year than all of the
country's cars according to new research
from the national housing federation
and the united nations patron of the
oceans is beginning to an attempt to
complete the coldest swim on earth lewis
pew is swimming across the 10 kilometer
mouth of the illusion ice fjord which is
fed by the world's fastest moving
glacier he's calling for more nations to
join an initiative to protect 30 of the
world's oceans by 2030 stressing to
world leaders that healthy oceans can
help mitigate climate change
now if you've enjoyed a staycation this
year visiting popular tourist sites in
the uk then this story is for you the
national trust is warning that
traditional summer holiday trips could
be under threat because of climate
change they say that temporary closures
due to flooding and storms as well as
extreme heat could mean visitors need to
adapt their plans in the future well
lizzie carlisle is the national trust
head of climate and environment and she
joins me now welcome to you so how might
uk holidays be affected by climate
change in the future
hi uh well thanks for having me on um i
think what our research has showed is
that um
with the increasing hot days that we're
likely to get
and increasing
downpours and intense periods of
rainfall we will see changing visitor
patterns and and what we've shown
through this research is that uh we
might see a shift in season so the
summer may just become too hot to be our
peak season and that might shift into
autumn
uh but we'll also see i think
visitor surges so when the weather does
get hot
uh we know that people love to go
outdoors into the coast and i think
we're already beginning to see what the
impact of those visitor surges look like
but we're expecting to see
far more of those as as the temperature
rises
and what can you do to protect your
sites and protect the public from some
of the risks associated with climate
change
well i think the first thing to say is
that we haven't got all the answers and
and this research is really trying to
kick off where we should look
i mean certainly we know there are some
everyday things that we can do like
providing shady
uh seating or lovely woodland walks that
will help people enjoy our places
in more extreme climates i think we're
also thinking about
how we hold water back in the catchment
away from our places to avoid flooding
for example
and finally just
engaging with our visitors and
helping them understand how to enjoy our
places without without damaging them so
not littering for example
and siestas for your workers in the
summer
well that's one of the options that
we're we're considering and testing a
couple of places but certainly you know
the same the same uh principles apply to
our visitors as they do our our staff
and volunteers we really want to make
sure that everyone can enjoy our places
and that might mean that our staff and
volunteers
choose to work in slightly different
patterns earlier in the day later in the
day to avoid those
those high
peaks of heat at lunch
um but but it's just one of the measures
that we're looking at to to try and make
sure that we're adapting our places to
climate change
lizzie carlile thanks very much indeed
thank you
they're known as eco engineers and for
many the work beavers do creating
natural wetlands and diverse habitats is
crucial to restoring nature but the
semi-aquatic creatures can cause
significant damage to farmland through
flood damage
now a government consultation will
establish whether beavers should be
officially reintroduced to the wild in
england for the first time in 400 years
as fraser ward reports
here in devon for the past few years a
community of hard-working
environmentalists has been steadily
growing under the watchful eye of local
wildlife groups and the government
no one knows quite how eurasian beavers
were originally released into the river
otter but now defra are starting a
consultation to see if more of these
construction loving rodents can be
reintroduced elsewhere
one of the effects of climate change
will be more extreme weather seen for
example in the form of more
intense rainfall episodes which can
cause flooding and also more droughts
and beavers at both ends of that
spectrum of dry and wet can help us cope
by reducing the flood peaks that go down
rivers after heavy rain and also holding
back water like this wonderful sponge
we're standing in today if it didn't
rain for a long time the river would
still flow because of the work that the
beavers are doing here
the dams which beavers build can raise
water levels and form wetlands these
areas as well as creating habitats for a
wide range of plants and animals are
also thought to be useful environments
for storing carbon potentially reducing
the emission of greenhouse gases that
cause climate change
some landowners and anglers have
concerns about the impact the beavers
may have hence the government's 12-week
consultation beaver's in the right place
can do amazing things
beavers in the wrong place can cause
damage for flooding farms flooding
property
taking out trees
flooding roads and we've seen all that
in this trial so we've learnt a lot
about beavers and the good they can do
but also the need to be ma the need for
management so that the the damage and
risks they cause to property can be uh
mitigated
others see them as natural and effective
ecosystem engineers
most of our rivers and watercourses in
this country are very straightened uh
very canalized what beavers do is they
bring that natural dynamism back so they
create dams and ponds and riffles and
all these are important habitats for
other species so uh in the work we've
done here on this trial we've seen
insects increased we've seen birds
increase we've seen the diversity of
plants increase
those who support the reintroduction of
a species made extinct in the uk back in
the 16th century hope that it'll provide
damning evidence that their return will
have a positive environmental impact
[Applause]
fraser moored sky news
well that's everything from us for today
next time lessons with a difference how
teaching landowners about rewilding
could help boost biodiversity you can
see that here on the daily climate show
tomorrow on sky news see you then
[Music]